l ag bouger mais aussi les vosgiens est
ce que vous préférez votre père ou votre
mère j'ai l'avertir
c'est pas possible je pars actions
d'intérêt que je peux pas je vois
monseigneur di falco qui attend là-bas
rassurez vous monseigneur cette
interview on l'a fait à samuel le bihan
donc vous y avez échappé defacto alors
plus simple est ce que vous préférez
staline ou hitler
j'ai envie de dire staline mais c'est
pourquoi il a tué plus de gens quittent
leh voilà et puis c'est ça un peu plus
plus méconnu c'est un peu moins proche
parent est d'accord mais les liens
saison informé du goulag que dès que de
jeunes c'est vrai alors ça c'est déjà
plus simple vous êtes trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec kad
et o ù bataille et fontaine tu dis ce
que tu veux on ne voudra pas ce que tu
as à me servir à voir les films pour
même aux jeunes un peu plus j'ai déjà vu
leurs émissions et voilà ça me fait
marrer locales et aux gentils bonne
bourre avec son maquillage
avait pas contre nous allons à tous tous
les deux oiseaux
j'ai tué ma mission bien alors vous
partez coupât me parties à ne pas sa
caisse monsieur à votre émission ces
conditions le pain sa quéquette c'est
pas trop service public en mains alors
[ __ ] vous partez sur une île
déserte sous partie sur une île déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou une fille très laide
fitr et l'inde
vous n'êtes pas [ __ ] du tout mais pas du
tout oui désolé dit non mais voilà j'ai
jamais vu ça quand même préféré préfère
une fille très lettre qu'un mec très
beau avec à son bord deux jours je
trouve ça très belle donc
oui bon elle il est tout petit j'ai
oublié de dire y'a pas on peut pas se
planquer 1
est-ce que vous accordez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles c'est quel âge
les petites 14 ans à 14 ans est rude je
préfère ceux qui tapent les vieilles
vous rappelle des comptes ou bien votre
finition préféré c'est être peint ces
mordus ou piquer amants du j'aime bien
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore oui oui pendant qu'elle n'en est
rien merci merci c'est lassant en tant
qu on n'a rien foutu
merci alors samuel je deviens un
perroquet mais j'évite un perroquet
voulu apprendriez quoi comme phrase tu à
fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco et j'avais averti c'est des
questions
c'était un type noël dernier un bien
vrai que si tu veux les perroquets ah
oui ça c'est terrible ça vous trouvez
votre fiancée au lit avec depardieu
ça c'est chiant questions qu'est ce que
vous faites
ryle éclate vous restez qu'est ce que
vous faites alors vous restez tiens vous
mettez au lit avec eux et je regarde
vous regardez oui vous gifle et votre
fiancée vous boudez vous tuer vous
parler boulot parce que si c'est peu
je sodomise depardieu
catherine me dit c'est vrai catherine sa
productrice de l'émission elle dit pour
un mec n'est pas [ __ ] il se domine
facilement depardieu aurait bien vu
catherine et dj falcon
du pacte des loups le christ en revanche
qui sort le 21 janvier
voilà alors on compare souvent cette
émission un dîner en ville et dans